A departed director, unpaid cast and crew, and
an outdated premise. These are just a few of
the problems that plagued what would sadly turn
out to be Kirstie Alley's last theatrical film.
The actress, who died of cancer on December 5,
2002, was best known for playing bar manager
Rebecca Howe on "Cheers" from 1987
until 1993. Alley won two Emmy Awards
for the role. She also starred alongside John
Travolta in three "Look Who's Talking" films,
and on "Veronica's Closet" from 1997 until
2000, earning another Emmy nomination.
Though she'd later appear in some TV projects such
as "Scream Queens," her film acting career came to
an undistinguished end. Her last theatrical
film, 2015's "Accidental Love," was plagued
by budget issues and abandoned by director
David O. Russell before its limited release.
According to Entertainment Weekly, before his
own departure, Russell clashed with James Caan
over Caan's character's death scene, leading
to the veteran actor leaving the movie and his
part being recast. The film, originally
titled "Nailed," was actually never even
technically finished, and several key
actors, not including Alley, left the
production because the studio reportedly
left some of the cast and crew unpaid.
When the movie finally made it to
theaters, it was not received well,
earning the approval of just 8% of
critics and 15% of audience members
on Rotten Tomatoes. Richard Roeper
of the Chicago Sun-Times wrote:
He went on to call the movie itself
"an unmitigated disaster," adding:
Here's the plot: A skating food server
named Alice, played by Jessica Biel,
is accidentally shot in the head with a nail gun.
"That's your brain, you know?"
"Yeah, that's my brain, so
please stop pushing on it."
The movie follows her bizarre experiences
seeking treatment and a normal life afterward.
Those experiences include meeting a man with
a prolapsed colon, played by Tracy Morgan,
and seeking care from a reverend with a
persistent erection, played by Kurt Fuller.
The film's attempted underlying message about
the lack of affordable health care in the United
States was simply buried under crude jokes like
these. Critic James Mottram wrote of the film,
Many critics also noted that "Accidental
Love" was seemingly past its sell-by date.
Filming started in 2008, the year
Barack Obama was elected president.
By the time the movie was released
in 2015, the Affordable Care Act,
or "Obamacare" as it's popularly known, had
been in effect for five years. The movie
was a satire of a health care system that
had changed drastically during production.
"Wait! She has no insurance. Shut it down."
"Thank you, Arlene! You're an angel."
Bilge Ebiri of Vulture wrote,
Prairie Miller of WBAI radio in
New York noted that the film was
co-written by former Vice President
Al Gore's daughter Kristin Gore,
based on her novel "Sammy's
Hill". She wrote of the film,
The stellar cast wasn't enough to save the film,
and neither was the onslaught of crass jokes. The
long and sad story of "Accidental Love" should
serve as a cautionary tale for studio executives,
directors, and actors alike to choose their
projects carefully. Although the careers of
Alley, Biel, Morgan, James Marsden,
Beverly D'Angelo, Jake Gyllenhaal,
and many more were not permanently tarnished
by their appearances in "Accidental Love,"
the film's infamous production lives
on as a warning of what not to do.
Fortunately, Alley completed the Lifetime TV
movie "You Can't Take My Daughter" five years
after the debacle that was "Accidental
Love." If not for the former film,
as well as appearances in TV shows like
"Flaked," the movie once known as "Nailed!"
would have been the last memory we have of a
talented, versatile, and accomplished actor.